[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 83 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MIKE MANDEL: I'm doing
very, very, very well.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm pretty good.
It's been a long week.
But you know, pretty good.
I'm very excited about
a very cool episode
about public datasets.
MIKE MANDEL: Yeah,
it's super cool,
where we talk about how we host
all these really large datasets
for all these people to play
with, and do fun things with.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I've used some of them before.
My favorite one is, we have
a lot of good from GitHub,
so you can do cool
things with it.
But it's not the only one.
So we're going to be talking
about a bunch of different ones
that you can just go and
use and have fun with them.
And after that, we have
a question of the week--
actually, a question of
the week whose answer
comes from someone we
interviewed in the future.
[LAUGHTER]
So at some point, we'll
have him on the podcast.
But for now, we have
something that he
proposes as a way
to have a better
understanding of your billing--
specifically, what goes where.
So if you've seen the
billing dashboard,
it's not as detailed
as it could be.
So how can you see more?
MIKE MANDEL: And with pretty
graphs and colors and stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Beautiful graphs.
Yeah, so we'll cover
that at the end.
It's going to be a
pretty cool thing.
It actually looks
really awesome.
But before that,
we have, as always,
our Cool Things of the Week.
MIKE MANDEL: Australia.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay, Sydney.
What's "E-N-Y?"
MIKE MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
I wrote "Sydeny."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, "Sydeny."
MIKE MANDEL: It's a story
back from the Olympics,
like way back.
That's showing how old I am.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
like an internal joke
between Australian people?
MIKE MANDEL: No, when Sydney
got announced as the Olympics,
I think it was called "Sydeny."
That was just because
the guy had an accent.
And it's a very stupid joke.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
only Australian's care.
But maybe, there is some
Australian listening
to the podcast.
Maybe they're laughing now.
MIKE MANDEL: Maybe.
Anyway, the important
thing is that now, we
have a region in
Sydney, which is
a pretty big deal,
considering how
far away from the
rest of the world
that Australia actually is.
So latency really
makes a difference.
So we definitely now have
a new region in Sydney
that you can take
advantage of right now.
We've got a good chunk of
our products available there.
They're not all there yet.
But we're working on some of
the pieces that are missing--
but especially if you
use Container Engine,
which I am a huge
fan of, as well
as some of our other stuff.
That's all sitting there
and waiting for you to go.
So I'm hugely excited.
I'm hugely excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean, I
would also be hugely excited.
Because right now, like, if you
were in places like Indonesia
before, you didn't really
have that much coverage.
Now, you have Singapore on one
side, and Sydney on the other,
and then Taiwan, a
little bit higher up.
So now you start to be really,
really, really well covered.
It's pretty amazing.
MIKE MANDEL: Yeah, no, super,
super excited about that.
And we keep growing and
growing and growing,
which I'm super happy about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One more
excuse to go to Australia.
We have, then, two different
stories that are really cool.
They're successful-- otherwise,
I wouldn't have you here,
I guess--
successful immigration stries
to Google Cloud Platform.
So one of them is how Bugfender
migrated to Google Cloud
Platform from
Amazon Web Services.
And it's really cool.
I really like their graphics.
I don't know if they
have someone working
on them specifically
or what, but they
look really, really cute.
And then, on the other
side, we have another story
where we have a different
company, this time migrating
from on-prem to
Google Cloud Platform.
And the name of the
company is, I think,
MeilleursAgents Because
I think it's French.
MIKE MANDEL: It might be French.
Or I could go with "Muellers."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: MeilleursAgents
means better agents, in French.
MIKE MANDEL: There you go.
OK, cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like
to hear you saying this.
MIKE MANDEL: No, I
just ruined it, then.
I'm not going to do it again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah.
It's a different company, a
different immigration story,
from a different place.
But again, successful.
And I think that for
many of our listeners
will be a definitely
interesting story to read
MIKE MANDEL: Yeah, no, love it.
I love both of them, definitely.
And they both come from
different perspectives.
And the one from--
I'm not going to pronounce it--
the real estate
company that starts
with "M," because I'm
going to ruin that,
totally, they have
great pictures
to show how their architecture
works, and what they changed
and what they didn't
change going across
from prem to Cloud.
They're both really good
articles, well worth reading.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is really cool,
because it goes
through the detail
on how, like, OK, so how do we
do it to have infrastructures
good, and, like, our own
click deployments, and stuff
like that.
So we're going to
use Jenkins, we're
going to be using Ansible.
It gets in a lot of detail.
So it is definitely
worth having a look,
especially if you're going
considering migrating
to Google Cloud platofrm.
There's definitely
lessons to be learned.
MIKE MANDEL: All right, cool.
So why don't we go get
stuck into public datasets
sets with Mike and Will.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MIKE MANDEL: A huge thank
you to the two gentlemen
joining us today.
We are joined by Mike Hamberg,
partner/operations manager
at gTech Feeds, as well as
Will Curran, program manager
at Google Cloud.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
How are you both doing?
Mike, how's it going today?
MIKE HAMBERG: It's going great.
Glad to be here.
MIKE MANDEL: Wonderful.
Wonderful.
And will, how are you doing?
WILL CURRAN: Coffee's
coming along good.
Glad to be here.
MIKE MANDEL: Excellent.
Excellent.
It is a little earlier
than we usually get up.
But thank you so
much for joining us.
We are here today to talk to you
about public datasets on Google
Cloud Platform.
But before we do that,
why don't we just
have a quick chat about who you
are and what you do at Google.
Will, why don't you go first?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah, I'm a program
manager with Google Cloud
up here in the Seattle office.
And I'm focused on data
and analytics partners.
And I'm very passionate
about improving access
to the world's datasets.
One of the programs I manage
is the Cloud public datasets
program.
MIKE MANDEL: Cool.
And you, Mike?
MIKE HAMBERG: I'm a
partner operations
manager here in the
Pittsburgh office of Google.
And I work on taking data
feeds and moving them around.
So in this case, we're
moving them to Cloud,
putting then in the
public datasets program,
and doing all the
transformations
that happen along with that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So Will, you mentioned that
you manage the public datasets
programs.
What is it exactly?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah, so the
public datasets program
launched just over a year
ago our Big Next Conference
in 2016.
And what it is is
a program where
Google Cloud hosts open
datasets in BigQuery, and also
Google Cloud Storage.
And we do a significant
amount of ETL on the datasets.
We're not just mirroring
them in Google Cloud.
We're improving accessibility.
So for example,
some of the datasets
that we have ingested from
data.gov, Mike's team's
done some ETL on those to
get those into BigQuery.
And what that does
for users is, it
allows them via
serverless access,
to query those datasets
via the UI or command line.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What is ETL?
WILL CURRAN: Mike, you want
to jump in and cover that,
since that's your part?
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah.
That's extract,
transform, and load--
so basically, getting the
data from the source, doing
whatever we need to
do it make it pretty--
sometimes that's optimizing
it, or denormalizing it,
or whatever needs to happen--
and then, loading it, in
this case, into BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So at the end, we end
up with a dataset that
is ready to be used
by anyone, and that
is available either on BigQuery
on Google Cloud Storage.
Is that right?
WILL CURRAN: Yes.
MIKE MANDEL: Awesome.
So can you give
us a few examples
of what datasets
we have available,
either on GCS or
BigQuery or wherever?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah.
So we've got a growing
number of them.
Some of the most popular ones
are GitHub, the Stack Overflow
dataset, Hacker News,
and then one that we
have a good relationship with--
NOAA-- and have been
ingesting more and more
of their weather-related
datasets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually,
out of those datasets,
I've worked with two of them--
NOAA, I gave a talk.
That was my first talk at
Google I/O, a long time ago.
Yeah-- on how to visualize all
the ships in the world using
BigQuery and Google Maps.
It is a really cool dataset.
It's amazing.
So that is now open
for everyone to use?
WILL CURRAN: That's correct.
Yeah.
We have several NOAA datasets.
We have global, historical,
daily, and monthly.
And then Mike just complete
onboarding of ICODES.
MIKE MANDEL: What are ICODES?
MIKE HAMBERG: That's all of
the ocean's information back
to 1662--
so ships, buoys, wind
temperatures, water temps,
where the ships were.
It's pretty comprehensive.
WILL CURRAN: We answer a
really interesting question
with that dataset, too.
MIKE MANDEL: What was that?
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah.
So we took a look at
where the Titanic sank,
and the hours surrounding
it, and did a visualization
on where other ships were--
so both the shipping lanes
in the hours before and hours
after the Titanic sank.
It's really neat, because you
can take this historical data
and plot, very visually,
what's going on at that time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
We were talking about
datasets there in BigQuery,
and it sounds like there's a
bunch of them that are super
cool and really easy to use.
But we've sort of touched
on it very briefly
in the short time
we've been talking,
about datasets we've got
in Google Cloud Storage.
What are those datasets?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah.
So the main datasets that we
have in Google Cloud Storage--
we've got about one and a half
petabytes of satellite data
from both NASA and ESA--
the European Space Agency.
And these are images that are
updated on a weekly basis,
as more satellite
images come in.
And then we also just
completed onboarding
of over 400,000 open art images
from the Metropolitan Museum.
These images are interesting
because they also include
annotations of that art--
so for example, what
era they came from,
who the artist was,
what the date was.
And then we can run
those like a Vision API,
and output those
annotations into BigQuery,
so that between Google
Cloud Storage and BigQuery,
you can do a lot of
interesting analysis on that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So there's a lot
of cool datasets.
And I'm kind of getting
excited about them
and I want to use them.
What are the conditions?
Can I use them for
whatever I want?
Is there licenses?
What are the conditions here?
WILL CURRAN: So the main
criteria for the program
is that the data be
open for public use.
Some of the datasets carry an
additional requirement that
they cannot be used
for commercial use.
But that is explicit on
the license associated
with the dataset
when you access it.
But for the most part, they're
free for use for public,
commercial, whatever you
want to use them for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So now I'm wondering, since
you were talking about the fact
that you do ETL--
the extract, transform,
and load process
to transform that raw data
into an actual dataset, what
other kind of things
that you do to that.
And what are the
most important things
that someone might be interested
in doing on their own data
before they load it to BigQuery?
MIKE HAMBERG:
Yeah, there's a lot
of pieces to that I think
we've learned along the way.
One of the most important
things-- something
that we always
talk about Google--
is eating your own dog food.
And essentially, what I
mean by that is trying out
the data for yourself.
Make sure it works for the
end users before releasing it.
So what we'll do is, we'll
go in and throw up a visual--
plot something in Data
Studio, or run a query
and get a result--
and make sure that the
values in the table
are going to work for the
analysts, the researchers,
the scientists,
the companies that
are going to use this data.
A very common thing that we
do is to denormalize the data,
and maybe take a
piece of information
that you would always
want with that table.
For example, we have
international census
information.
And in the international
census information,
it just has codes for
each of the countries.
And so the codes aren't
really that useful.
And every single time
you use the table,
you kind of need to look up,
like, what does code 34 mean?
And so you'd want to know
which country that is.
So we might join that
data in ahead of time
when we load the table
and put it in there.
There's a lot of standardization
that also goes into the data.
We try to take a smart look
at, what are some things that
would be helpful for developers,
or for anyone that might
be using it in the future?
So we would take fields
that maybe the dataset
has three different fields for--
a day, a month, and an hour.
And we can take those, and
we'll leave them there,
but we'll add a new
field that's a timestamp.
So that when somebody
goes to plot this data,
they don't have to
concatenate all these fields,
and transform hours in the
military time or regular time.
So we do a lot of analysis of
data ahead of time to prep it.
MIKE MANDEL: Out
of curiosity, how--
I don't want to use the word
"dirty--" but how messed up
do you find the
data tends to be?
Is it kind of all
over the place?
Do you find it's generally
inconsistent or consistent?
MIKE HAMBERG: It
depends on the source.
We get some very good data
from NOAA and other partners.
They spend a lot of
time in quality control
with their data.
Others sources, not
so much, I would say.
But the trick is,
with the government--
especially in the US here--
they have this mandate
to open up the data,
so they get the data out
there, but often, it's
not in a usable format.
It's in a weird file encoding,
or it's in some arcane setup
that they have on their side,
maybe with their terminology.
It doesn't make sense for
the majority of users.
So we end up bringing that
in, trying to parse it,
figure out what's in there,
what's useful for people.
And we do a lot of
joining of tables
and bringing stuff together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So now I'm wondering,
you're saying
that you adapt that
raw data before you
even put it into BigQuery.
And I'm imagining that that
could be kind of a big thing.
There's a lot of data.
You need to process it,
parse it, clean it, whatever.
How do you actually do this?
I imagined I would use MapReduce
or maybe Dataflow, something
like that.
Can you talk a little
bit about this?
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah, we
have an internal tool
that we use to actually
pipe the data through.
But we definitely use the
techniques like you mentioned,
often doing MapReduce to
consolidate rows or expand
rows.
We might go from many
columns to many rows,
if that makes sense,
or vice versa.
And we have a connector
that picks up data via FTP,
or HTTPS, or whatever protocol
is used to post the data.
And then we have a
loader for BigQuery.
And we do use the BigQuery
API to load that data in.
MIKE MANDEL: I just assumed it
was a big Drive spreadsheet.
That's how I just figured.
MIKE HAMBERG: Well,
it's a challenge, too,
because often, this is
100 million rows of data.
So it's massive datasets
that go through.
And especially, one
of the key things
that we do that's different
than a lot of other places
you might find this data is,
we have a live connection.
So if that data
updates in 30 minutes,
we are piping another
iteration of that through,
which means that people
just need to go to BigQuery.
They'll have the most fresh
data that's available.
MIKE MANDEL: So I'm
actually curious.
You say live.
What does live mean?
Obviously, in the big data
space, seconds is nice.
But are we talking hours, days?
What's that live feed like?
Obviously, it depends, I guess.
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah, it
depends on the source
and how often they update.
I would say it tends to mean
hourly, or maybe every five
to 30 minutes.
But when they're really
big datasets, even
someone like NOAA, they're
not posting these that often,
because they're so
huge, for storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
next question, I guess,
is, you were mentioning that
NOAA, for instance, they're
a very good partner and that
they give really good data.
But we also have a lot of
other different partners
that provide us with data.
Why do they do it?
Why would they do
this thing for free?
WILL CURRAN: Well,
in a lot of cases,
as Mike mentioned
before, especially
with government data,
there's a mandate
to make this data available.
But what we're
learning, especially
through the
relationship with NOAA,
is not only are they incurring
more storage costs over time.
If they didn't add any
more data, over time,
those costs are mounting.
But also, they're collecting
more and more data.
You know, we're moving into
this Internet of things world,
where there's more
monitoring devices.
And so their data is growing
daily, exponentially.
So the problem
they have is, they
have to distribute
this data to--
they have thousands
of users that
are interested in
this weather data.
And so nevermind their
own storage costs,
the egress charges are
getting out of control.
And so what they see is
valuable from different platform
partners that have these open
datasets programs like ours
is that they can push
distribution to, like, five
platforms, and then point
users to those platforms,
so that they aren't
incurring egress
on NOAA's servers every minute.
So we're seeing
this example as we
talk to more and more partners
that have open datasets.
MIKE MANDEL: Excellent.
WILL CURRAN: And then
there are some other cases
where a non-government
agency that has open data,
they're releasing that
open data with the hopes
that people will run
like an ML use case on it
to do some interesting things
that they just don't have
the resources to do internally.
MIKE MANDEL: So that segues
into my next question, which
is, what sort of
stuff have you seen
people do with these datasets
that have been particularly
interesting?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah, so
our own Felipe Hoffa
had kind of teed this off.
I don't know if you
remember the Silicon
Valley show where they had
the tabs versus spaces debate.
And so Philippe took
the Github dataset
that we had to kind
of prove this debate.
And he ran several queries
to show that, in fact, spaces
were most popular in every
language except ironically, Go.
So that was a pretty
interesting analysis
that got picked up by a lot
of the different communities.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I saw that analysis,
and I really liked it.
Especially, I mean,
I'm a "Go-pher."
I write Go all the time.
MIKE MANDEL: Really,
I didn't know that.
I had no idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Shocking, I know.
But the funny thing
is that, yeah, there's
a lot of people that
was like, oh, in Go,
everyone writes tabs.
And then in other
language, everybody
writes spaces, which is fine.
But then some languages were
like, well, it's half-half.
WILL CURRAN: Yeah,
that's not good.
MIKE MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is not good.
Cool.
Is there any other use case?
I'm thinking about,
for instance, there
was this really cool contests
with Kaggle, the YouTube thing.
MIKE MANDEL: Oh,
the eight million--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
do you have any big dataset that
people could use for machine
learning that
cannot be big scale?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah, like
I mentioned before,
we're releasing the Metropolitan
Museum open art images .
And then we're also working with
some different third parties
that provide medical
image datasets.
So these would be
radiology images.
And one of the
use cases there is
that the community can
run machine learning
on these radiology images to
try to classify and detect
different anomalies
in those images,
whether they're tumors
or different growths.
So we're trying
to find all sorts
of different large datasets
that are public domain
to provide to the
community to start
building different
classification models.
MIKE MANDEL: Cool.
Mike, did you have any other
examples you wanted to add?
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah.
We've been doing a lot
of work around city data.
That's been a hot topic around.
Data.gov and these
cities are opening up
a lot of their information
about how the city works,
and things like 311 calls, or
fire station response, police
incidents, stuff like that.
So [? Raido, ?] who is a
developer advocate on our team,
has been doing some
interesting analysis--
things like, where is
your car most likely to be
broken into in San Francisco?
Or how long does it take the
fire station to get to a fire?
He did a really cool thing
in New York City about,
which borough is
the rat capital,
based on 311 calls
about rat complaints?
But there's all kinds
of interesting city data
that's out there and available.
And we're really just
starting to pick up on that,
bring that into BigQuery so
people can dream up new things,
and also, analyze across cities.
I think that's one of the really
big values of the program,
is taking one dataset
and merging it
with another dataset.
For example, some
of the medical data,
they merged that
with the census data.
And so because we have all
those datasets available,
it's easy to join them, and
pull in other information,
and make your dataset
more compelling.
WILL CURRAN: Yeah,
[? Raido's ?] stuff
is really interesting,
too, as Mike mentioned.
Because he's also pulling
in weather-related data
to show how there's different
correlations between events
from the city data.
MIKE MANDEL: Interesting--
so seeing if rain affects--
I don't know-- cab
traffic, or something.
WILL CURRAN: Yeah, cab
traffic, bike usage.
And he also uses just to show
that you may see correlations,
but that doesn't
necessarily mean
there's a statistical reason.
One was-- I can't
remember, Mike-- wasn't it
something like, on
snow days, there
was a higher percentage
of last manhole covers,
or something weird like that?
MIKE HAMBERG: That's great.
Yeah, that's something
we should do,
is the whole spurious
correlation data.
MIKE MANDEL: I'm also wondering
if there's opportunity here
to do competitions
between cities.
Because you know how cities
love to have rivalries.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah it could be fun.
MIKE MANDEL: That
could be lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
wondering-- a long time ago,
when I used the NOAA dataset,
one of the things that I ended
up using at the same time
was this other dataset that
allowed me to basically go
from country to continent,
for instance.
Is there such a dataset.
It's basically like the
Knowledge Graph for Google.
I don't know if you know
Google Knowledge Graph.
It allows you to
basically ask about facts.
Is there such a thing that you
can mix with BigQuery easily
to ask that kind of questions?
MIKE HAMBERG: Facts about
countries around the world?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, for instance,
let's say that you
have a dataset.
And the dataset is telling you
about things about countries.
But your question is actually,
I don't care about the country,
I care about the
continent level.
So now, you want to ask,
well, given the country,
give me the continent.
Is there such a
generic or general data
set that people can use?
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah, we've
been building these--
what we call utility datasets.
And so a pretty good
example of that is,
you might have a data with
addresses or zip codes
that you want to know--
actually, plot these, with
latitude and longitude.
So we've been building these
join tables, essentially,
that are there.
I don't think we have one
that is country to continent.
But that'd be pretty easy
to set up, since there's not
very many continents.
But we do have,
especially in the US, all
the different
geographical points
like zip code, state, county--
all that stuff, you can pull in.
And then we're doing some stuff
on some future datasets that
will have kind of a
more comprehensive look
at the different data
you can pull together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Could
you share a little bit
on what data sets
are you working on,
or something like that?
What datasets do you
think people might get
excited about that are coming?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah, I'll start.
And then, Mike, you
can add to this.
We're working on, like
Mike mentioned earlier,
trying to get more
city-themed datasets in--
so like, Austin, London.
I've also started doing
some research on what
it would take to get Tokyo in.
The problem is that in order to
do interesting joint analysis
between these datasets, you
have to have common joint keys.
And there's no really
standard schema
for all this municipal data.
So trying to patch it together--
and it's a lot of the
work that Mike's doing--
and trying to make it so
that it can join together
is quite a challenge.
But I'm hoping that we see more
and more of these datasets come
out of the
municipalities, so that we
can start doing different
analysis across cities.
MIKE HAMBERG: And a dataset that
I'm excited about, that we just
launched, and that
we're also working on,
is around air quality.
So we're all wandering around
cities in different places,
and we don't really
necessarily pay attention
to the quality of the air.
And so we recently released
27 years worth of EPA data
that shows all the different
particulates in the atmosphere,
and for thousands of
locations around the US.
And we're working on
some future stuff that
will show even more real-time
information about what's
going on around the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice, that
sounds really useful and scary.
[LAUGHS] So we're kind
of running out of time,
but is there anything
else that you'd like
to mention before we finish?
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah,
so as we mentioned,
we've been partnering
with NOAA, and we
have lots of really great
partners in the data space.
And quick success story
that I can share--
in the first few
months of this year,
we diffused about 200
times the amount of traffic
that they would have
expected on their datasets
with people using
the BigQuery instead.
So this is real
savings for them,
because they don't have to
incur that cost of both load
on their datasets, and
also all those egress
charges that they get.
This is saving taxpayer dollars,
and also making their data
more accessible and available.
And that's a big, important
goal for the government.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Awesome, so I guess
that the last question
is, if someone
has a huge dataset that
they'd like to share,
how do they get in touch?
WILL CURRAN: Yeah,
we'd love to hear
from the community on
what other datasets
they'd like to see
in the program.
They can reach out
to us by emailing
GCP-public-data@google.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And we'll have a link to
that email in the show notes.
WILL CURRAN: And you'll hear
from either Mike or myself.
MIKE MANDEL: Fantastic.
All right.
Well, Will, Mike, thank
you so much for joining us.
I want to sit down and go
play with these datasets.
We really appreciate
you taking the time
to chat to us about
the public datasets
that we have available
on Google Cloud.
WILL CURRAN: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
MIKE HAMBERG: Yeah, it's great.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks so
much again to both Mike Hamberg
and Will Curran for
taking the time today
to talk to us about all
of these really, really
interesting datasets.
There's definitely
datasets that I knew about
and that I was like,
oh, they're cool.
But I didn't know
of many of them.
So I'm going to be
definitely using
some of those for my demos.
But I know that
some of the people
might be able to use it
for actual, useful things.
MIKE MANDEL: Actual,
useful things rather than
just ridiculous stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
like ridiculous demos.
They're fun.
MIKE MANDEL: Excellent.
All right.
Well, why don't we get stuck
into the question of the week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
I think the question of the
week was basically, OK, so, I'm
able to see how much money
I'm paying for Google Cloud
Platform.
And I'm able to see pretty much
from a high-level point of view
why the money's being billed.
Like, you're able to see
that many hours of whatever
kind of instance you're using,
or storage, or networking,
or stuff like that.
But I actually want
to have a better view.
Like, I really want to drill
into more detail in the data.
How do I do this?
MIKE MANDEL: So
this is really cool.
This is an article that was
written by Mike Zinni and Ryan
McDowell--
we'll have links to all of
this in the show notes--
where they combine Google
Cloud's building export
to BigQuery functionality
with Google Data Studio, which
is a really great tool
for visualizing data
that's inside BigQuery.
And what they do
is, they basically
put together a variety of
graphs and filterable UIs
that you can use to
see, really at a glance,
but also at a deeper level,
exactly what's going on
inside your project, and
across projects, as well.
And so you can see, I'm
looking at App Engine
spend, for example.
Or I'm seeing comparatively
different products
that I'm using across
all of my projects.
And it gives me a lot of
insight into exactly what's
going on inside my projects and
my applications, and the money
that I'm spending.
What's super sweet
about this is that--
we'll link to this, as well--
the demo that is
available so you can go
see exactly what
this dashboard looks
like has a How to Copy
section, which is super cool.
And it has step-by-step
things, so you
don't have to build
this thing from scratch
and import all the SQL
statements they're doing,
or anything like that.
It's literally five, six, seven
steps-- something like that--
to basically copy all
this stuff across,
creating a datastore
in BigQuery,
copying across the workbook,
and then you can take advantage
of this thing, and then
customize it if you so desire--
that kind of stuff.
And it's super
super, super nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In
my opinion, actually,
the cool thing is not the
fact that you can copy it.
Copying it is cool.
I think that the cool thing is
that this is just framework,
and you can build
on top of this,
and adapt it to
whatever project you're
using, which is pretty amazing.
Like, if you know
how to use SQL,
you know how to use
BigQuery, and now, you
can do pretty amazing queries
to basically drill down
into your actual data, and then
present it in a super cute way.
Cloud Data Studio-- it allows
you to expose information
in a very, very
visual way, meaning
that, even though you're
working with hard data,
you're able to present it so
anyone can understand what's
going on, which is
very, very nice.
MIKE MANDEL: In the
article, it links
to a video that was from
Next this year, that was done
by Ian Lewis and Vic
Iglesias, explaining basically
all the details around this.
But they show some
stuff in there
where you can do stuff to,
say, predict the future.
Like, where do you think your
building's going in what you're
doing, and some fancy math to
enable that to happen, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
no, it is really cool.
As soon as you start
having lots of data,
you're able to do analysis.
With BigQuery, you're able to do
not only analysis of the past,
but also, like, very
good predictions.
And not only that,
but what I really like
is that you're able to
do even correlations.
There's very advanced
correlation analysis
on BigQuery that are just
functions that you can call.
You can find correlation, which
could help you find causation
on your billing things,
which is really, really cool.
Basically, if you're
a data scientist,
you should get very
excited about these tools.
MIKE MANDEL: [LAUGHS] Excellent.
All right, well, Francesc,
we are running out of time.
But what are you up to?
What are you doing?
What's cool and
exciting in your world?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by
the time this comes out,
I will be already in New
York for QCon New York City.
We're going to be presenting
Go Tooling in Action workshop,
based on the video that I
published a long time ago--
Go Tooling in Action.
And this is going
to be open-sourced.
So it will be in my GitHub soon.
MIKE MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm working on it.
It's a lot of content.
But it will be there by
Friday, because that's
when I'm running the workshop.
And then after that,
I'm coming back
to San Francisco for a week.
And then I'm gone
again, this time
to Denver for Gophercon,
where I will be also running
two workshops.
Kubernetes and GOPC and
stuff like that, all in Go.
What about you?
MIKE MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, literally, the
day this comes out,
that evening, here
in San Francisco,
we'll be hosting
Playcrafting yet again.
They're doing their
June Playtest night.
So we're hosting them.
And it's always fun to go
down and see all the games
that people are
working on and get
to play them and do all
sorts of fun stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And pizza.
MIKE MANDEL: And pizza.
There's definitely pizza.
And as well as that,
in July, I will be
going to the New York Summit.
That will be on
the 18th of July.
I will be talking with a company
called Phoenix One Games.
They have a new multiplayer
mobile game called Guardian
Kingdoms that's out right now.
We'll be talking about
their infrastructure
and how they built
their stuff on GCP.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That sounds lots of fun.
So have fun in New York.
MIKE MANDEL: I will.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I will
have fun in New York, too.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, again, for
being part of the podcast.
Actually, maybe it's time
to remember to our listeners
how to get in touch with us.
We've been getting more
questions, which is awesome.
We want those questions.
Keep on sending them.
And the way to send them
is through our email--
MIKE MANDEL: Hello@GCBpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
can also get in touch
with us via Twitter--
MIKE MANDEL: @GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Or on Google+--
MIKE MANDEL: +GCBpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have subreddit.
MIKE MANDEL: /r/GCBPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
are also in Slack.
MIKE MANDEL: On the Hash podcast
channel, on bit.ly/GCP-Slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Finally,
all of those things
are actually accessible
from our web page--
MIKE MANDEL: At GCBpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
MIKE MANDEL: That
sounds really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
so again, thank you.
And thank you all for listening.
MIKE MANDEL: Wonderful.
And see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]